en el vídeo anterior vimos que si
comenzamos con una estrella que tiene
una masa de 9 a 20 masas solares y
cuando está madura finalmente el
remanente de la estrella o el núcleo del
remanente de la estrella tiene una masa
de 1.5 a 3 veces la masa del sol
esta estrella y quiero aclarar que esta
masa de 9 a 20 veces la del sol es la
masa de la estrella cuando no se
encuentra en la secuencia principal y la
masa de 1.3 a 3 masas solares es cuando
la estrella ha expulsado su material y
esta es la masa del remanente que queda
es el núcleo de la estrella pero este
remanente una vez que ha terminado de
usar su material y cuando deja de tener
presión del exterior y tiene la
suficiente densidad en el vídeo anterior
vimos que esto causará una supernova una
onda de choque que se moverá en el resto
del material y en esencia lo expulsara y
esto se condensará en una estrella de
neutrones de lo que quiero hablar en
este vídeo es qué pasaría si
comenzáramos con una estrella que fuera
más masiva estos cálculos son una
aproximación no sabemos con exactitud la
cantidad de masa necesaria exacta para
que suceda esto pero qué pasaría si
comenzáramos con una estrella que
tuviera
a veces la masa del sol y este sería la
masa original antes de que la estrella
comience a arder o cuando la estrella ha
alcanzado la vejez cuando su núcleo se
vuelve de acero el remanente denso
tendrá una masa de más de tres o cuatro
veces la masa del sol
recuerden que si el núcleo es tres o
cuatro veces más masivo que el sol la
estrella era mucho más densa esto es
solamente el núcleo de níquel ya es cero
que ya no se está fusionando que sucede
con esas estrellas pues son tan masivas
que incluso la presión de repulsión del
neutrón no será suficiente para evitar
que la masa implosión y esas estrellas
toda la masa de estas estrellas
continuará su inclusión recordemos que
las estrellas como el sol van a colapsar
en enanas blancas quizá deba dibujarla
en blanco
colapsaran en enanas blancas esta es una
enana blanca y aquí la presión que evita
que el núcleo se siga colapsando es la
presión de repulsión del electrón los
átomos se aprietan tanto que son sus
electrones los que evitan que se sigan
apretando más pero si la presión aumenta
más entonces tendremos una estrella de
neutrones tendremos más masa en un lugar
más pequeño y aquí no estoy dibujando
esta escala estas estrellas son
diminutas las enanas blancas tienen un
tamaño parecido al de la tierra en el
vídeo anterior vimos que las estrellas
de neutrones tienen un tamaño similar al
de una ciudad son súper densas tienen
más masa que esto y quizás debería
dibujarlo como un punto para darnos una
idea de su densidad es como un gran y
denso núcleo atómico sigue siendo
pequeño pero tiene el tamaño de una
ciudad
es un núcleo del tamaño de una ciudad y
algo poco intuitivo de estos dibujos es
que mientras más pequeños son más masa
tienen este de aquí superó la presión de
repulsión del electrón por lo que
colapso aún más pero si la más es lo
suficientemente grande y es de lo que
estamos hablando en este vídeo incluso
la presión de repulsión del neutrón no
será lo suficiente para evitar el
colapso de esta masa hay en teoría
estrellas quark en donde la presión de
repulsión del quark es lo que evita que
la masa siga colapsando
pero podemos ir más allá si tenemos más
masa llegará un momento en que toda la
masa se colapsará en un punto y aquí lo
estoy simplificando colapsa en un punto
de densidad infinita
y esta es la masa de un agujero negro
porque hay varias maneras en las que
podemos decir que comienza o termina un
agujero negro o que es exactamente el
agujero negro así que esto es toda la
masa del agujero negro o podríamos decir
que es toda la masa de la estrella
original cuando decimos que el remanente
tiene más de tres o cuatro masas solares
toda esa masa bueno no todas muchas de
la masa se libera como energía de la
supernova y eso también se cumple para
la estrella de neutrones
pero la mayor parte de la masa ahora
está contenida en este punto
infinitamente pequeño y escucharán que
físicos y matemáticos hablan de las
singularidades y las singularidades son
puntos incluso en matemáticas en lo que
todo se descompone en donde ya nada
tiene sentido en donde las ecuaciones
matemáticas ya no nos dan respuestas
definidas esta es una singularidad
porque tenemos una tremenda cantidad de
masa en espacio infinitamente pequeño en
esencia tenemos aquí una densidad
infinita y algo que es muy difícil de
visualizar tenemos una curvatura
infinita del espacio-tiempo
yo no puedo visualizar esto y quizá en
próximos vídeos hablemos más sobre ello
pero cuando dije que hay varias formas
de definir qué es y dónde comienza o
termina un agujero negro es porque aquí
es donde está la masa y si hubiera otra
masa por aquí sería
traída por esta masa y se volvería parte
de dicha singularidad y aumentaría lo
que ya es una masa tremendamente grande
en este punto infinitamente pequeño pero
la razón por la que es difícil definir
los límites es porque cierto punto en el
espacio alrededor de la singularidad en
la que sin importar que haya o cuánta
energía tenga el objeto no podrá escapar
de la influencia gravitatoria del
agujero negro de esta masa ultra densa
incluso la radiación electromagnética
aún cuando fue la luz que se aleja de la
masa eventualmente caerá hacia la
singularidad sin poder escapar de la
influencia gravitatoria por lo que el
límite en el cual si lo atravesamos que
en realidad es una esfera la frontera
alrededor de la singularidad que si la
atravesamos no importa que hagamos o si
fuéramos radiación electromagnética
nunca escaparía moss del agujero negro
pero si estamos afuera de dicha frontera
podríamos alejarnos del agujero negro
este tipo de acá podría escapar pero
este tipo de acá no importa lo que haga
va a caer hacia el agujero negro
a este límite o frontera le llamamos
horizonte de eventos que es otra palabra
muy usada en películas de ciencia
ficción y por una buena razón es
fascinante en futuros vídeos
hablaremos de la radiación de hawking
que no es una radiación propia del
agujero negro sino que es una
consecuencia o subproducto de efectos
cuánticos que ocurren en el horizonte de
eventos pero el horizonte de eventos es
este punto en el espacio o esta esfera
en el espacio que es el límite en el
espacio en la que dentro de ella
cualquier cosa inevitablemente terminará
en la singularidad contribuyendo a dicha
masa y cualquier cosa fuera de ella aún
tiene la oportunidad de escapar así que
como se ve un agujero negro pues ya que
ni la luz puede escapar de él se verá
negro en el sentido puro de que no emite
tipo alguno de luz o radiación desde
este agujero negro o desde su masa aquí
hay algunas ilustraciones sobre agujeros
negros que obtuve
y solo para aclarar qué es lo que sucede
aquí estos negros que vemos aquí no es
el agujero negro cuando la gente habla
de agujeros negros es normalmente a esto
a lo que se refiere pero hay un punto
con densidad infinita en el centro de
esta esfera negra de aquí esta esfera
negra de aquí es en realidad el límite
del horizonte de eventos
y lo que vemos aquí es el disco de
acreción conforme toda esta materia se
acerca cada vez más y se estrecha más y
más se mueve cada vez más rápido y se
calienta más y más
esta imagen representa esto de aquí más
caliente con colores más brillantes en
comparación con la materia más fría de
afuera la cual se va a acelerar cada vez
conforme se acerca al horizonte de
eventos una vez que llegue al horizonte
de eventos no podemos ni ver la luz de
esta materia conforme se vuelve
tremendamente energética aquí hay otra
ilustración conceptual de un agujero
negro destrozando una estrella y bueno
todas son ilustraciones conceptuales no
fotografías nunca podríamos tener
imágenes reales tan buenas de un agujero
negro en la acción
esta imagen ilustra a una estrella
siendo destrozada por un agujero negro
pues esta estrella se ha acercado mucho
al agujero negro y se muestra que en
dónde está la estrella hay una gran
atracción gravitatoria
y cualquier material emitido por la
estrella en esa dirección será
lentamente atraída hacia el agujero
negro y así la estrella es destrozada
poco a poco por el agujero negro aquí
tenemos otra ilustración que lo muestra
mejor aquí hay una estrella que al
acercarse a un agujero negro comienza a
deformarse ya desintegrarse debido a la
influencia gravitatoria del agujero
negro se alarga y su materia comienza a
caer en espiral hacia el agujero negro
acercándose cada vez más hasta que llega
al horizonte de eventos en donde ya no
podemos verlo más pues incluso la luz de
dicha materia intensamente caliente que
está entrando al agujero no puede
escapar de él espero que hayan
encontrado esto interesante y quiero
aclarar que aún no comprendemos mucho
acerca de los agujeros negros de hecho
esta noción de que en la singularidad
toda la matemática y todas las teorías
dejan de funcionar como las conocemos es
una señal muy clara de que nuestro
conocimiento es incompleto
si fuera más completo podríamos dar una
explicación más coherente que decir que
todas las ecuaciones pierden sentido en
este punto infinitamente denso